we are asked to calculate the number of
moles in a 1.5 to kilogram sample of
glucose so like always pause this video
and try to figure this out on your own
and this periodic table of elements will
prove useful all right now if we're
trying to figure out the number of moles
remember mole is a really you confuse a
quantity of something if I set a dozen
of something you'd say oh that's 12 of
that thing if I say a mole of something
I'm saying that's Avogadro's number of
that thing and so we have a one point
five two kilogram sample of our molecule
in question of glucose so if we can
figure out the mass per mole or another
way to think about it the molar mass of
glucose well then we just divide the
mass of our sample by the mass per mole
and we'll know how many moles we have so
what is the molar mass of glucose well
to figure that out and that's why this
periodic table of elements is useful we
just have to figure out the molar mass
of the constituent elements so if we
first look at carbon carbon we see from
this periodic table of elements has a
molar mass of 12.01 grams per mole we've
talked about in other videos you could
view this 12.01 as the relative atomic
mass of a carbon atom of as the average
atomic mass of a carbon atom or what's
useful and this is where Avogadro's
number is valuable if you have
Avogadro's number of carbons it is going
to have a mass of 12.01 grams so carbon
has a molar mass of 12.01 grams per mole
and now we can think about hydrogen in
the same way hydrogen has a molar mass
of 1.008 grams per mole zero zero eight
grams per mole and then last but not
least we have oxygen here oxygen we can
see from our periodic table of elements
it has a molar mass of 16 point zero
zero grams per mole and so now we have
all the information we need from our
periodic table of elements so the molar
mass of glucose is going to be six times
the molar mass of
armen plus 12 times the molar mass of
hydrogen plus 6 times the molar mass of
oxygen so it's going to be 6 times 12.01
grams per mole plus 12 times one point
zero zero eight grams per mole plus
every molecule of glucose has six
oxygens plus 6 times 16 point zero zero
grams per mole
six times twelve point zero one plus
twelve times one point zero zero eight
plus six times 16 is equal to and if
we're thinking about significant figures
here the molar mass of hydrogen goes to
the thousands place but we only go to
the hundredths for carbon and for oxygen
we're adding all these up together so
it's going to be 180 point I can only go
to the hundreds place for significant
figures so 180 point one six so that's
equal to 180 point one six grams per
mole and we could say grams of glucose
c6h12o6 per mole of glucose c6h12o6 and
then we can use this one point five two
kilograms to figure out how many moles
we have so if we start off with one
point five two kilograms of glucose so
that's c6 h-12 o-6
well first we can convert it to grams
because here our molar mass is given in
terms of grams so times we're going to
want kilograms in the denominator and
grams in the numerator so how many grams
are there per kilogram well we have
1,000 grams for every one kilogram so
when you multiply these two out this is
going to give you the number of grams we
have of glucose which would be 1520 and
if you have your mass in terms of grams
you can then divide by your molar mass
or you could view it as multiplying it
by
the moles per gram so for every 1 mole
of glucose c6h12o6 we have 180 0.16
grams of glucose C c6 h-12 o-6 and this
is going to get us we get 1 point 5 2
times 1000 is equal to this is the
number of grams of glucose we have and
then we're going to divide by 180 point
1 6 divided by 180 point 1 6 gives us
this number and let's see if we see
significant figures we have three
significant figures here we have five
years we want to round it to three
significant figures so it will be eight
point four four moles of glucose so our
kilograms cancel with our kilograms and
then our grams of glucose cancel with
our grams of glucose and we are left
with eight point four four moles of
glucose moles of c6 h-12 o-6 and we are
done